all right so the next session uh will be
about um um on friday uh 15 february
february 18th
and uh we will start a little bit early
for this session the first session then
um basically what we are going to do is
to is to understand uh
the uh ngs workflow so before starting
the ngs next generation sequencing
workflow usually what we do is isolate
and purify your nucleic acid and then uh
dna extraction methods also can
introduce inhibitors which can affect
the workflow so there are some other
steps that we are going to discuss that
what is being used before data analysis
so i mean we will also discuss that
different
methods
for virus discovery right like cell
culture inoculation sequence independent
pcrs they have been used and now the
emergence of ngs that has entirely
changed the field of virus discovery so
we discussed that in the first half of
the session so um in the next session we
will be discussing about this technology
illuminate technology so
a clinical genomics specialist from
premise life sciences a company which is
focused on illumina sequencing and is uh
specializes on
like helping
scientific community with uh the
instruments and
um and the analysis and all of that so
uh doctor so raj javerman will be
letting us know i will be helping us
learn about all of that uh the initial
steps so and it would be followed by
another
session i mean
by one of the experts
from premas which will be about finding
ngs data from
public repositories uh so we will be
looking at
once the data is you know prepared and
it is
it is being generated by the machine
how do you go to the next step uh how do
you prepare your data to be submitted
and when it is submitted
and it is on a public portal and it is
on a public repository
how do you understand where it is how do
you find that information relevant to
your project and also like um
getting to that data and how to
interpret that entry so that is uh one
of the challenge that many students
faced so we thought that it would be
nice to have a guest session in this
program where uh experts who are working
on this every day can come and tell you
about these things and so that we can
all on all learn about it
so that's about uh the
two sessions that we have next uh on
on february 18th but we have a lot of
upcoming wonderful opportunities and
exciting sessions coming up in march so
in march we are going to start with a
program
which is a short workshop for three days
it's about genomic surveillance of
saskof2
variant of concerns
so in this program we will be speaking
about importance of genomic surveillance
for noble emerging variants and
consequences of large scale by
vaccination on its evolution so as we
were discussing that throughout this in
this presentation so in this in this
short workshop we will be
doing uh different kind of activities
so that would be also include that would
also include like generating a report so
if anyone was working on coronavirus uh
saskoof2 and other viruses and if uh
what is the purpose of doing that
analysis so generating and finding that
in a form of a report that actually
helps to understand the analysis in a
very simple way and also to do this at a
genomic level so this program will con
will be like this short workshop will
cover all those things so let me quickly
take you through the sessions that we
have planned for this for this uh start
workshop starting from first march to
third match so we will start with a
session that would be about you know
ngs uh iot pcr and how to detect uh
viral particles sequencing of genome
genomes and detection of variants
so we will be talking about uh
established protocols like illuminatic
protocol used for full genome sequencing
and pcr primers for variant tracking so
this would be the first introductory
session that is for genomic surveillance
where we will be learning about all the
data collection methods then in the next
session uh we will be learning about
using ngs data to find uh
using one second please
so yeah in the next session we will be
reviewing i will it will be a hands-on
session uh completely so here we will be
learning learn to load uh files from ngs
pipeline into r using custom scripts and
how this is uh and then uh before that
we will be learning how to build a
pipeline and how to
understand the outputs of these
different algorithms that are used in a
workflow which is a pipeline for genomic
analysis or viral genome analysis so
this will be the second session uh that
will be an hour after the first session
and after that we will have a con we
will have another introductory session
session on nature of emerging variants
why they are causing concern why what
might be the driving force behind the
observed plates or substrings of this
virus as it continues to spread around
the world so that's the overview and we
in this session we will be learning
about uh from a data perspective so we
will be going to ncbi virus and we will
be looking at different strains and then
we will be doing analysis on the t bind
for platform where we will be learning
about how they differ and what how
they're emerging and connecting it to
the palagini so this is the first
session which is another beginner's day
these are these are the first day plan
uh it will be for three hours or two and
a half hour
and a half hours and the second day
which is the day two
um
which is on wednesday second march uh we
will have an uh asynchronous session
which would be not a live session in
this session we will be expecting the
participants who are joining the
workshop and doing it with us
uh to learn about uh these different
resources and courses that you can
already do it in the infectious disease
program as well but in addition to that
there will be assignments to do some
covet code related research and analysis
so this is the day two and after that
the third day would be a research level
uh
uh
meetings we will have research level
uh analysis so in this uh in this
session what we are going to do
is that we are going to learn about
um one second there are some chats that
we are getting so in this session we are
going to learn about um the hands-on
analysis uh for the logic behind like
developing a workflow so what are the
different variant workflows that we are
using and how these samples that are
varying from like clinical samples to
environmental samples to waste water how
they are how they are being utilized to
do this sort of analysis and how many uh
universities and many pis and a lot of
data is emerging from these sort of
analysis and what is the next step and
how it is going to help us so all of
that will be covered in the introductory
session uh session followed by the
research level session that would be
followed by the second session which
would be about the downstream analysis
of genomic data if evolutionary studies
and then biology journey and
origin tracing and reporting so this is
another specialized session
i mean
designed for those who are
going to who have interest in going in
depth into into the
variation understanding and
understanding how it could impact at a
level of
you know the question research question
so this will be in the next session
followed by that we will be learning how
all of this could be
made into a report that could be uh that
could give us insights about this entire
analysis that we have performed for
variant and how that correlates for
whenever vaccine implications or at as
as a structure structural level how it
reflects so understanding the impact of
the mutation and finding from the heap
of data and like all those uh
difficulties that make this analysis
really challenging we would want we
would be simplifying that uh throughout
this entire uh workshop and one of the
reasons
what we are doing this is also that we
are launching this as a research support
as a research support so many who are
interested in
analyzing their data we will be able to
help them analyze uh their data through
this
so this is what i wanted to share and i
would be looking at the questions if
there are any and would be i would